[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les femmes ça fait péd c'est très
efféminé tellement eff féminé que ça
fait
péd les femmes ça met des jupes non mais
de quoi je m'occupe les femmes ça me
débat non ou soit
les femmes ça fait péd c'est très très
efféminin tellement efféminé ça fait
P les femmes ça met du rouge à lèv et
quand ça bouge des ça fait marcher les
[Musique]
PDG les femmes ça fait P c'est très très
très
tellement efféminin que ça fait
péter les femmes ça se
parfume les femmes sa bois sa fument des
liqueurs de banane et des
[Musique]
havanes les femmes ça met du rouge à
lèvres et quand ça bouge des hanches ça
fait marcher les
PDG les femmes ça fait péd c'est très
très très
efféminé tellement efféminé ça
fait les femmes ça
fait tellement
féminin qu'il y a plus d'un péd qui est
resté
foreign